visez comment encore garder le maillot
fun que rachida avait le même pull over
sept reprises abaissé la chanson qui
l'attendait pascal sevran
c'est la chanson française la plus
reprise oui avec la deuxième c est
maintenant ou il ya la troisième il y
aurait il ya aussi les chancelière
donc quand l'arrêté de nos amours la mer
mois 200 sont très d'accord que
reste-t-il et la mer et puis beaucoup
d'autres mais c'est le code d'éthique et
en effet c'est la plus reprise d'altis
et et non mais quand même remarquable
chanson française quand je ne remarque à
la chanson française elle fut au tour
d'hugo et parce que quand elle garde sa
spécificité de veut parier un singe et
d'autres c'est une très très bonne
chanson mais alors et alors il leur fait
leur métier s'est pas est-ce que c'est
pas un problème est qu'elles ont vu
finalement les auteurs compositeurs les
jeunes auteurs qui veulent vous êtes un
auteur compositeur the bakery 500 ch en
rejeter les textes on en connaît d'eux
que les 498 outre ouais on connaît il
venait d'avoir 18 ans et c'est déjà pas
mal à se faire
oui mais j'ai fait beaucoup autre chose
puis la gentillesse peur de le dire ne
veux pas parler de ça je voulais dire
que une chanson c'est un texte en france
en tout cas et une musique et donc et
quand les jeunes gens d'aujourd'hui qui
veulent faire de la musique seront ce
que c'est ça ira une chanson il doit y
avoir une musique
s'il n'y a pas de musique ça ne va pas
donc comme maintenant la plupart de ceux
qui veulent maintenant de faire de la
musique ne font pas ça va pas on peut
être dans son époque on peut danser
rythme parfaitement mais faire de la
musique ça sent fait autre chose
et alors pourquoi s'émouvoir sur ses
chansons qu'on vient de citer ya une
mélodie et une mélodie on la met sur la
mer sur problème et on avait sonné
rythme qu'on veut il ya une mélodie
parce que ce que dit pascal sait
aujourd'hui si la plume des reprises
c'est parce que plus personne n'est
capable d'écrire des chansons chez ce
qui lie le moment actuel en france et
maintenant il ya beaucoup plus de
créations beaucoup plus de musique à
vent s'est désolé mais attendez à
l'époque de johnny de claude françois
ils ont fait des reprises
oui ils se sont fait connaître d'un
petit j'ai entendu quelqu'un quand
michel berger avec jeune âge avec cabrel
les calmes une époque où la chanson
française et pas besoin de faire des
reprises pour faire un tube
des reprises j'en ai fait plein et pour
que ces des hommages que en chansons
qu'on aime et défend leur donne
véritablement un souffle nouveau
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une demande de
la part de l'industrie est relayée par
part parlé par les radios qui préfèrent
quelque chose qui est déjà connue parce
qu'on fait des panels faut quand même le
dire c'est à dire qu'on appelle des gens
qu'on leur fait écouter un petit bout de
chanson pendant trois secondes dans
leurs faits et les gens aiment un
cantique honnête il faut comme ça quand
ils connaissent pas ils font comme ça
alors on en est ce qu'on peut dire
pardon c'est pas mesdames si l'on peut
dire concernant lit ou par exemple ces
cas là pardon
elle a un disque liot que j'ai écouté
quand même passer des chansons dans
certaines émissions de ges produites qui
est prêt et bien les gens lui font faire
des best-of les gens lui disent lio tu
fais des best-of vous en êtes à votre
deuxième best of
entre temps un album qui s'appelait vent
data room america précieusement
précédente
voilà donc vous êtes vraiment l'exemple
des notables qu'on pense que là c'est
dur je pars dans ces durs non c'est bien
sûr que c'est pas dur dur c'est pas bon
il ya un fort faut relativiser les
choses plus dures dans l'existence mon
chanter là je me produis aux coulisses
bon effectivement j'essaie de monter sur
scène pour montrer aux gens aux
personnes notamment les autres personnes
qui ont parlé sur moi donc de soi disant
que je elles ne connaissent pas ce que
je fais donc alors je chante et
vis-à-vis de tous les interprètes comme
avec rachid par les interprètes français
moi je dis français dans la mesure où si
la langue française alors je suis arabe
aussi bien aux arabes espagne tu t'en
fous toi mais moi je m'en fous pas mal
être je suis normale en moyenne cheveux
clairs je suis interprète de la variété
française bon que vous dites qu'il ya
une pauvreté qu'aujourd'hui il ya moins
de l'interprète
mais dans ce cas là que les que les gens
se déplacent on skie ce qui est pour moi
moi j'ai demandé à des gens de venir me
voir des à des journalistes d ils se
déplacent pas ils veulent pas se
déplacer
tu as eu ses chances par exemple
stéphane vous pensez qu'elle va y
arriver que à la raison de s'accrocher
je suis incapable de le dire très
sincèrement je ne connais pas tout avec
tout ce qui a été dit
je ne suis pas moi contre vous dit tout
avec tout ce qui a été dit je peux vous
garantir que je vis aujourd'hui un vrai
préjudice moral et un préjudice
artistique en foire pour tout artiste
pour tout artiste c'est simple de parler
bon pour cheat ailleurs il a sa maison
de disques il est tranquille il n'a pas
été attaquée par personne il a été
attaqué par personne il est tranquille
moi j'ai eu toute la presse sur le dos
et j'ai eu des artistes c'est plus de
vie non j'ai eu mais ceci dit dans le
préjudice moral il ya un artiste il ya
un individu qui est là et là il ya des
producteurs
il ya un gros staff sur le coteau les
individus pas des producteurs et bien
moi je suis l'individu concerné et
l'individu maintenant l'individu
concerné l'individu concerné il est là
et il a souffert pendant 3 donc pendant
trois ans je vis ce préjudice moral et
je ne le vis pas seul je le vis avec un
auteur je le dis avec un compositeur
je le dis avec toute une équipe et toute
une équipe ça déstabilise toute une
équipe de dire ses fans pour qu'on avait
c'est ça les recteurs les
téléspectateurs gilles faugère il a tu
peux aller sur place par le public
voilà merci je l'a expliqué aux
téléspectateurs parce que sinon personne
va comprendre c'est qu'effectivement il
ya eu un problème en 1995 aux victoires
de la musique
stéphen a été meilleure révélation de
l'année et on s'est aperçu que le
producteur de son disque était en même
temps le producteur de l'émission les
victoires de la musique c'est monsieur
denis leamy donc ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'effectivement ça fait un
scandale parce que les gens ont dit il
n'est pas normal que le producteur du
disque de stan honey sur le même
producteur que l'émission et thierry
séchan ici présent a dit que c'était une
arnaque
voilà pourquoi vous êtes énervé on a
tous dit voilà alors j'explique aux gens
parce que sinon je chéris de transférer
trouve ça étonnant oui oui j'avais dit
c'est tout ce que vous avez dit
agitation lisais dans l'iss ionnaires
révélations le mot révélation ce qui
doit être révélé
tu dois fait que la future surgit
retirer la chose suivante c'est que j'ai
été
j'étais dans ce film un donc révélation
j'ai été nommée lauréate je gagne je
n'ai pas moi je sais pas je prends un
prix je pars je vais chanter je vais
amener quelque chose de gens je vais
donner quelque chose moi c'est pour
donner c'est pour donner du bonheur
donner de la joie
je suis pas là pour me faire oublier je
suis pas là restent opposés il faut
aussi parler du système bons souvenirs
vous chantez une reprise oui alors que
j'adore d'ailleurs beauchemin la musique
pour des cons superbe en russie perçue
comme une peau noire une reprise qui a
été écrit par emile ngoy musique
absolument show must go est énorme en
glace il faut dire pour que les gens
suivante investisseurs attendaient pour
que les gens suivent dans ce qui s'est
passé en même temps va chanter trop bien
finir qui s'est passé c'est donc le tpn
a été accusée d' arnaque par départ
place par plein de gens d'ailleurs les
victoires de la musique non plus été
produite par la société qui la
produisent l époque à distribuer sa
fille coco gens et vous avez d'une
information qui est fausse si je vois
pas le producteur de la musique
administrateurs musique c'est claude oui
c'était le patron des différents mais
les écossais veulent oublier
oui et c'est que tous les auteurs
pointent à la ligne c'est tout et et
dennis lim on sait simplement qu'il a
disparu toute façon ce n'est plus mon
gros producteur sam et serge valérie
alors pour le comique c'est parfait
c'est le patron d'ercis a maintenant
pascal sevran vous êtes vous connaissez
la faire vous avez quelque chose à en
dire
claire rien